RYAN MATSUMOTO: Today we're
talking about GKE image
streaming, Student
Success Services,
and 5G network slicing.
I'm Ryan, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest-latency news.
We're excited to announce
the general availability
of a new feature in
Google Kubernetes Engine--
image streaming.
This revolutionary GKE
feature has the potential
to drastically improve your
application scale-up time,
allowing you to respond
to increased user demand
more rapidly and save
money by provisioning
less spare capacity.
We achieve this by
reducing the image pull
time for your container
from several minutes,
in the case of large images,
to a couple of seconds,
irrespective of container size,
and allowing your application
to start booting immediately
while GKE streams the container
data in parallel.
A recent survey found
that 87% of companies
reported that they are
now experiencing skills
gaps now or in the coming year.
And the impact of
the pandemic has only
added to the urgency for
schools and education-technology
companies to find new ways to
support even more learners.
To meet these challenges and
scale specialized learning
across more students
globally, we
are expanding our portfolio
of Student Success Services
with a new Google Cloud
artificial intelligence-powered
learning platform, which
features the Interactive Tutor.
This platform will provide
new ways for educators
to share curriculum and will
bring more on-demand learning
opportunities to students.
Building on the recent releases
of the Android 12 operating
system and Google
Distributed Cloud,
Google is paving the way
for communication service
providers, as well
as enterprises,
to deliver enterprise
applications and services
over 5G network slices for
enhanced application security,
reliability, and performance.
5G network slicing enables
virtual mobile networks
to be created dynamically with
varying properties utilizing
shared underlying
physical resources.
5G slicing is one of the
key areas of innovations
that will let CSPs earn a return
on their investments in 5G
by offering a secure
and dynamic network
platform to enterprises.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.